- I spent a lot of time in
my 20's waiting for someone
to tell me that it was my time,
and expecting someone to say,
okay I'm gonna step aside
and now it's your turn,
and that's not a thing,
so you need to make your own time
and take your own turn.
- Mistakes are okay as long
as they don't kill you.
Things change, so live
your life in chapters.
- Don't compare yourself to other people.
Realize that you don't know
what people are going through,
so don't think that
everyone is better than you.
- I would tell myself that
I deserve good things,
I deserve to be loved and happy,
and have people in my life who like me
for all my weird quirks.
- If I had known that
I would be the person
that I am today without them,
I would've left a long time ago.
That is when I really
learned that it is okay
to be selfish.
- Don't stop playing piano
just because you found another passion.
Keep two passions, keep too many passions.
- I think it's important to
realize that everybody is human
and has limited experiences,
no one is an authority.
- You know better than
anyone what's best for you.
- It is completely okay to be weird.
I have been very accustomed
to being the odd one out,
and it led me to the best things possible.
- If you feel it in your heart,
and you believe it's right, lean into it.
- [Wavy Hair Girl] Don't
try to change yourself
for other people.
- Your curls are amazing!